NATO defense ministers are in Brussels
to discuss efforts around support for
Ukraine yesterday G7 leaders recommitted
in assisting Ukraine in terms of
humanitarian financial and of course
military support and this comes after
the country saw widespread attacks that
haven't been seen since the start of
Russia's full invasion with more on
today's meeting and what we might expect
let's bring in our Europe bureau chief
Crystal gomancing who joins us from
London Crystal we appreciate this so
let's talk about what is on the agenda
today and who is there
good Morning Anthony yeah this is a
regular meeting that we have seen now
NATO defense ministers getting together
in Brussels uh in addition to the NATO
defense ministers we're also seeing
Ukraine's defense minister on hand as a
special guest of course Canada's
minister of National Defense Anita Anand
is there as well we saw her in Poland
yesterday making another announcement as
far as Canada's contribution to
supporting Ukraine's efforts and
fighting for its sovereignty about 40
combat engineers will be taking part in
training Ukrainian soldiers in Poland
with Ukrainian soldiers so it is really
an ongoing Collective effort that we're
seeing so the thought right now the talk
right now from Ukrainian officials is
their ask is for air defense systems of
course you mentioned all of those
attacks and those strikes that we saw on
Monday right across the country with
deadly impacts and that is really coming
down to shelling and missile strikes in
so many different locations so we saw
Ukraine's President Vladimir zielinski
asking for missile defense systems
modern missile defense systems one from
Germany is now in action you're taking a
look at a foot bridge that actually
wasn't destroyed but was in fact area
was hit nearby just a harrowing
situation all over the country with
these you know rockets and missiles
raining down people being told right
across the country if you hear those Air
Raid Sirens make sure you are in fact
seeking shelter so that's again why
we're seeing those NATO defense
ministers meeting right now in Brussels
but Anthony in addition to that regular
NATO defense ministers meeting there is
even a bigger meeting of of allies it's
called the Ukrainian defense contact
group and that's more than 50 countries
they're having side meetings again
trying to talk about what further
supports they can provide to Ukraine as
as this war now enters it's 231st day so
we're hearing of contributions we're
hearing of announcements and certainly
plenty of overtures and words and
condemnations the question is how much
more needs to be done how much more is
the International Community willing to
offer we know what Ukraine is asking for
whether the International Community will
go further is the big question isn't it
it really is and it's been a continuous
ask it has been for
um you know land defense systems for for
modern technology it was a lot about
m77s and high Mars uh you know just a
few weeks ago of course they still need
those weapons they still need Munitions
and those supplies but it's now sort of
being spread out a little bit and if you
go back to even in the early days there
were many calls for air defense systems
so it is a continuous call for support a
continuous call for really advanced
modern weapon systems that NATO
countries have and we have heard a
number of countries saying yes we will
recommit we will help we heard the
Secretary General of NATO yesterday
saying that you know he's glad that
countries are stepping up to the table
once again to help protect Ukraine
saying that Ukraine must win this war
not only for Ukraine but for uh all
um you know democracies right around the
world so there is a desire it's just we
don't know if it's actually going to
turn into anything immediate and that's
what it really comes down to is even if
there is a commitment for more weapons
more air defense systems when will they
actually get on the ground to be put
into action Crystal I'm wondering in
your reporting shed light on some of
this and we're talking about some of the
impacts of these assaults on Ukraine and
and I'm kind of getting to the bigger
backdrop of of energy really being a
focus of of this war electricity and
various things and and talk about what
the impact is right now for ukrainians
because as we know it is approaching
winter and that is becoming more dire
and more difficult for so many people in
that country shed light on that if you
could
it is a huge huge issue Anthony if you
think of Ukraine Ukraine number one
people have to remember is a massive
country but it's also in terms of
weather very much like the the Canadian
Winters in in Winnipeg or or
Saskatchewan for example it is
incredibly cold a lot of buildings that
have been hit are residential buildings
there are energy plants for example in
La Vie four substations hit yesterday
two completely destroyed so the idea of
not having Windows not having walls what
will winter look like so it is a problem
in Ukraine and all over Europe frankly
because of energy supplies from Russia
and those those caps and sanctions
sanctions we're seeing Anthony could be
a grim winter we appreciate this as
always Crystal commencing are you your
Chief uh joining us from London thank
you again